[Music]
spring is the perfect time to flex your
green
thumb and this week is international
compost awareness week
it's a way to encourage you to be aware
of what you're tossing in the trash
because
some of it is not trash at all some of
the benefits of composting are a
reducing your waste
but b if you're a gardener like me it's
reintroducing
vital nutrients back into the soil so
you can have healthy
vibrant fruits vegetables herbs
leafy greens you know composting
is really just going to be bringing life
back into your garden
so here are some tips to get started
composting
first you have to understand what
materials and items should be composted
in the first place so maybe coffee
grounds fruit vegetable waste even tea
bags would work don't use meat obviously
in milk products
when it comes to your goals determine
where you're going to use the compost
maybe house plants are in a garden and
then
assess your space because you need a
place to hold your compost
maybe a bucket with a tight seal so it
doesn't stink up your house